Брак нерухомості у великих німецьких містах
плюс попит на оригінальні будинки, які нині в тренді,
призводять до того, що з нікому не потрібних будов
у Німеччині постають дуже навіть затребувані
житлові комплекси. Ось кілька прикладів.
Тишу цього місця вкрай рідко порушує якийсь звук.
Це колишній монастир кармелітів у Бонні.
Протягом століть тут жили ченці, а тепер
а високою монастирською кам'яною стіною мешкають
звичайні сім'ї. Монастир перетворили на житловий комплекс.
Забудовники, які задумали перебудову цієї території,
вже на початковому етапі залучили до проекту майбутніх мешканців,
щоб максимально врахувати їхні побажання.
Будівництво реалізували в два етапи.
Спершу з урахуванням усіх вимог з охорони архітектурних пам'яток
перебудували старе приміщення монастиря.
Тут з'явилися апартаменти для 31 сім'ї,
кілька офісів і навіть кафе, яке, до речі, було задумане
як місце зустрічі з іншими мешканцями району.
А щоб не було конфліктів через паркування, забудовник побудував гараж.
Якщо ідеться, наприклад, про перебудову монастиря на житловий будинок,
постає питання: а що, власне, важливо з точки зору
збереження архітектурної спадщини? Які вимоги до інвестора?
Відомство з охорони пам'яток формує певний перелік вимог,
щоб будівля зберегла старовинну атмосферу.
Але, як правило, відомства із захисту пам'яток навіть раді,
що старі будівлі збережуться. І досить охоче погоджуються на те,
що об'єкт змінює призначення, набуває нові функції.
Після того, як чернеча обитель стала сучасним житловим будинком,
на колишньому монастирському подвір'ї
з'явилися 16 таунхаусів і багатоквартирний будинок для 21 сім'ю.
80 відсотків усіх квартир
продали ще до початку будівництва.
Про привабливість нетривіальних будинків для людей
свідчить і цей проект, теж у Бонні.
Ця будівля на Ґете-алеї - колишній наземний бункер.
Протягом 70 років він не використовувався,
поки бункер не викупили в держави два інвестори,
які перетворили його на житловий будинок для п'ятьох сімей.
Головним викликом було питання з вікнами -
товщина бетонних стін у бункері близько метра.
Для монтажу отворів запросили фахівців з Берліна.
Крім того, згідно з приписами відомства з охорони пам'яток,
інвестори зобов'язані були мінімально втручатися у зовнішній вигляд бункера,
зберегти дах, цокольний поверх з кам'яною кладкою.
А також плющ і дикий виноград на будівлі з боку вулиці,
що вже стали невід'ємною частиною споруди.
Звісно, нині такі будинки користуються попитом.
Коли подібні об'єкти з'являються на ринку,  до них завжди є інтерес.
Тільки потім стає зрозуміло, що, власне, придбали - може пощастити, а може й ні.
В деякому сенсі старі будинки - як кіт у мішку.
А це - приклад того, як німці успішно перебудовують свої "хрущівки".
У спадщину від колишньої НДР залишилося чимало таких серійних будинків,
більшість з яких після возз'єднання Німеччини спорожніли і занепали.
Цьому потсдамському мікрорайону Древіц
з близько п'ятьма тисячами мешканців пощастило.
Тут успішно реалізують концепцію міста-саду.
Мета проекту - не просто відремонтувати житлові будинки,
але й осучаснити цілий мікрорайон
та звестИ до нуля викиди парникових газів у кварталі за рахунок
переходу на енергію з відновлювальних джерел.
а також створення вільної від автотранспорту зони.
Трамвай у центр міста ходить кожні десять хвилин.
Замість проїжджої частини - сквер і дитячі майданчики.
Стандартні фасади соціалістичних часів не впізнати.
Економічно найкращий варіант! Плюс - це ж надбання нації!
Не можна просто так брати і зносити будинки і будувати щось нове:
ані з точки зору економіки, ані з точки зору етики.
Адже це побудовано людьми, це частина історії,
люди тут цілі життя проживали, тут виростали покоління.
Ви тільки уявіть собі - ви приїжджаєте в місце, де ви народилися і виросли,
а його раптом немає! Це ж жахіття!
Важлива запорука реалізації таких проектів -
постійний діалог з місцевими жителями про майбутнє району.
На стадії планування відбулися десятки дискусій
про те, яким буде мікрорайон і скільки це коштуватиме.
Тим, кому довелося залишати квартири на час капітального ремонту,
влада оплатила переїзд в тимчасове житло - і назад.
Байдуже, бункер, монастир чи панельний мікрорайон -
усі ці приклади демонструють, що перш ніж зносити закинуту споруду,
варто підключити трохи архітектурної фантазії і підприємницький нюх .
І можливо, з нікому не потрібних будов можуть постати
дуже затребувані житлові комплекси.
Про доцільність таких проектів свідчить і те,
що порожніх квартир ні в колишньому бункері, ні в колишньому монастирі,
ні в колишніх панельних "хрущівках"
сьогодні, судячи з усього, не залишилося.